hello everyone this is outnumbered I'm
Kaylee mcineny here with my co-host
Emily compagno also joining us Martha
McCallum anchor and executive editor of
the story Dr Nicole Sapphire Fox News
contributor and board certified
radiologist and Ben Ferguson host of the
Ben Ferguson podcast and co-host of the
verdict with Ted Cruz podcast
we begin with President Biden's attempt
to win over Latino voters ahead of the
2024 election instead of focusing on
much bigger problems and folding at the
southern border he has some other plans
in mind Texas governor Abbott has
dropped off his first busload of
migrants in Los Angeles after it
declared itself a sanctuary City
Abbott says small Texas border towns
remain overrun and overwhelmed because
President Biden refuses to secure the
Border and Republican senator Josh
Hawley he blasted Homeland second to
secret security secretary excuse me
Alejandro mayorcas about the disturbing
reports of Migrant children being
exploited for cheap labor
000 migrant children unaccompanied
crossing the border in the last two
years and tens of thousands of them
being sold into slavery let's not mince
words they've been sold into slavery
he's right but back to Biden and those
plans I mentioned instead of dealing
with the southern border issue which is
serious and unprecedented the White
House they're holding a movie night to
lift up and celebrate Latinos tonight
President Biden and the first lady are
hosting a special screening of Eva
Longoria's flaming hot film that's the
title of it you know Martha absolutely
we can celebrate Hispanic heritage and
the great achievements as they're doing
with that movie but Democrats have a
really serious problem they need to look
at it's with latino voters 538 summed it
up this way of course a respected
polling site we took a look at the
numbers and found that yes Biden's
approval has dropped dramatically among
black Americans since he took office in
January of 2021 but the biggest decline
wasn't among black Americans it was
among Hispanic Americans he's seen
support dropped there by about 25
percent so if I'm Biden man I'm looking
at this with seriousness well that's the
question is it with seriousness when the
way to address it is this flaming High
got promotion that they're doing for Eva
Longoria's movie at the White House
which is about a factory worker at
Cheetos excuse me who came up with the
spicy hot version I looked at the
trailer it looks like a cute movie but
you know I'm also reminded of what
Senator Hawley talked about and that was
another young woman who was profiled in
The New York Times who worked at a
Cheerios Factory and she was 15 years
old she's one of these young people who
finds themselves you know barely a
teenager assigned to a life of slave
like factory work
tens of thousands of young people I have
interviewed people who work with these
children this is a real issue you never
hear a peep about it from the bite
Administration so it's the real life
things that Latino families go through
and that they see people from their home
countries going through that really
address what is going on and what their
concerns are so you know if the first
lady talks about you know what kind of
Taco are you and and the president plays
you know despacito on his cell phone
these things are
um I think they're seen as sort of
lightweight and and not addressing the
real issues so I don't know if this is
going to turn around a decade of
deterioration of Latino support for for
President Biden and Democrats Kaylee I
think that is spot on and you know I've
been saying for a while that Republicans
we need to come from a place of
compassion on this issue yes border
security so important but lean in on the
atrocities happening because of the lack
of Border policies and Josh Hawley did
just that I think every Republican
should watch what he said yesterday and
think of this as a template for how to
talk about these issues and lean into
them ahead of the election let's listen
to what he said it's on the issue of
children and the way the Biden
Administration is treated illegal
immigrant children
I tell you what I'm tired of I've had
secretary mayorkas sit in front of me in
a different committee the homeland
security committee where I asked him at
links about the outrage
of 250
000 migrant children unaccompanied
crossing the border in the last two
years and tens of thousands of them
being sold into slavery let's not mince
words they've been sold into slavery
when kids are being put into factories
forced to work overnight forced to work
in terrible conditions they're not
getting paid they're not going to school
sometimes they're not getting fed that's
slavery
powerful Biden slavery you could call it
of illegal immigrant children that's
right and he also went on to make the
point that the Biden Administration
refuses to accept responsibility and in
fact keeps deflecting right from agency
to agency oh that's the Department of
Health and Human Services oh no no
that's not us oh that's border security
oh no no that's not us keep in mind that
those are all portions of that same
bloated federal government under
President Biden's watch so to have the
American people expect that they would
swallow that type of deflection we'll
know they're out of this part of the
pipeline that's why we moved them it's a
shoving game on their part and to your
point yes the GOP needs to harness that
messaging which Dove tells perfectly in
with what you were saying Martha the
contrast between this Administration
that plans to spend seven figures on
different bilingual ads catering to
those different Spanish-speaking voters
they elected the granddaughter of Cesar
Chavez as part of the re-election
campaign it is window dressing when you
couple that with the horribly uh frankly
racist comments that have come out of
the mouths of the president and his wife
it is no wonder that the Latino
population which is an American
population feels patently offended at
what is clearly just propped up
performative activism on the part of the
administration because if they really
cared about Latinos which means
Americans then they would care about the
250 000 migrant children that are being
basically into slave labor they would
care about the missing and unaccounted
for 65 000 and they would care about
what every American cares about which is
the value of the dollar the kitchen
table issues Safety and Security
education the value of the the pension
that has now plummeted all of those
things that face Americans so them
harnessing they say they were going to
focus on Latino populations in Arizona
and Pennsylvania and California well
they need to focus on the issues that
would make all of the residents in all
of those States feel secure and
confident with this Administration which
are the GOP issues yes well Ben let's
watch that those comments from the first
lady that prompted Latino journalists to
say we are not taco watch
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community as distinct
as of the Bronx as beautiful as the
blossoms of Miami
San Antonio
[Applause]
it's dehumanizing it's also exploitation
on a political level and I think what
you're seeing from this Administration
is they're willing to exploit these
children who are being sold into sex
slavery human trafficking being sold off
as slave labor and they're doing it
while saying come to the White House and
watch a cool video about Cheetos tonight
and we're going to tell you that we're
on the side of Latinos I think he's got
a bigger problem Than People realize
because the Latino Community is very
tight-knit in America they're sick and
tired of the drugs they're sick and
tired of the gang violence they're sick
and tired of the dehumanization and
being treated this way where hey we'll
throw a knight at the White House for
you and watch a video and we're on your
team these children are being abused but
they're being abused not just by the
cartels they're being abused by the
Biden Administration and they're
deliberately doing it on purpose yeah
they certainly are and you mentioned
some of the Democrats plan to win over
Latinos as laid out by axios I reached
out to the RNC this morning and they
pointed to their community centers
Nicole which are in communities Latino
communities diverse communities Across
the Nation and they laid out how points
moved in their Direction when they
started getting on the ground and
sharing the message of conservatism with
Latinos so you have that you also have a
president I'm curious if he's going to
dance this election uh let's watch
despacito here with the president of the
United States I just have one thing to
say
hang on here
[Music]
there you go come on
I love this song I will say that like my
kids love that song too but let me first
of all between the president and the
first lady they completely make a
mockery of the entire Latin culture in
some of these little things that they do
they get the laughs sure and they get
some Applause but really it's an
embarrassment but the Biden campaign is
very smart in the sense that they do
have to focus on the Latin voters at
this point they make up about 15 of
voting Americans and they are the
fastest growing racial and ethnic group
for the electorate and Biden lost 10
points from Hillary Clinton in 2016 to
2020 and now his approval has already
gone down since 2022 midterms from about
65 to I think 34 so he is in trouble but
when it comes to Latin voters the
economy Still Remains the number one
issue and yes they had the child tax
credits they also had a lot of those
coveted release Leaf checks that helped
the Democrats in the 2022 midterms but
now every American not just Latin
Americans are feeling the economy right
now and so it's going to take more than
a Spanish-speaking website which had a
whole bunch of errors when it published
it's going to take what are they going
to do for the economy and that's where
they need to focus for Latin voters well
we know what they won't do because today
they put out a statement about deferred
action for childhood arrivals DACA the
anniversary well I seem to remember a
former president Trump who offered
temporary protection for DACA recipients
in exchange for border wall funding and
they turned it down I believe Kamala was
a Senator so maybe Joe go talk to Kamala
today